my family tells of an ancient legend
about ku great dragon brothers the
dragon of the north wind and the dragon
of the south wing
together they upheld balance and harmony
in the heavens
you
but the two brothers argued over who
could better rule their land the quarrel
turned a rage and their violent struggle
darkened skies until the dragon of the
south wind struck down his brother who
fell to earth shattering the land
the dragon of the south wind had
triumphed but his time passed and he
realized his solitude the sweetness of
victory turned to ash
you
for years the bereft dragons grief
through the world into discord
and he knew only bitterness and sorrow
one day a stranger caught up to the
dragon and asked o dragon lord why are
you so distraught the dragon told him
seeking power I killed my brother but
without him I am lost stranger replied
you have inflicted wounds upon yourself
but now you must heal walk the earth on
two feet as I do I'm valuing humility
then you will find peace
you are not the first assassin sent to
kill me and you will not be the last you
able to come to schemata castle the den
of your enemies this was once my home
did your masters not tell you who I want
you I know who you are how though I know
you come here every year on the same day
you risk so much to honor someone you
murder yo does nothing of what happened
I know you tell yourself that your
brother disobeyed the class and now you
have to kill him to maintain order that
it was your duty it was my duty and my
burden that does not mean I do not honor
him
ah
you think you are a your brother Genji
with incest offerings honor resides in
one's actions you did to lecture me
about honor you are not worthy
today night
you go I got the crown
only llamada can control the dragons who
are you do it then kill me
no I will not grant you the death you
wish for
you still have a purpose in this life
brother no
Oh my brother is dead
pinchy
the dragon knelt on the ground for the
first time he was able to clearly see
the world around him and he became human
the stranger revealed himself as his
fallen brother reunited the two set out
to rebuild what they had once destroyed
what have you become I have accepted
what I am and I have forgiven you
now you must forgive yourself the world
is changing once again hands up and it's
time to pick a side
real life is not like the stories our
father told us you're a fool for
believing it so perhaps I am a fool to
think there is still hope for you but I
do think on that brother
over watch coming to PC and consoles May
24th
you